[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
loud
and do not give a [__]
this is the Tony Michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not Liberty you [__]
eating [__] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the Tony Michaels podcast
and this is Tony Michaels
hey Tony [__] them
[Music]
I I said that I wanted Durham to go
before the Committees and what the
Democrats question them this morning it
happens uh Republicans throw out another
rake to step on and of course John
Durham is The Rake that they will step
on here and the reason why is because
this whole Durham thing was all ruse
anyways
it was all ruse it's all weaponization
of government that Trump used to appoint
a spec to get Bill Barr to a point of
special counsel to somehow lock Hillary
up and they couldn't do it and there's a
reason why
is because the collusion was actually
happening with the Trump campaign and
the government Adam Schiff this morning
absolutely [__] destroys Trump's
Lackey about an hour ago I guess or so
absolutely destroys John Durham
even Jerry Nadler [__] hands it up to
to John Durham gets John Durham to admit
the facts about investigating the
investigators it's all a bunch of
[__] all of it period
it always was Jesus Christ if you're not
aware Hunter Biden the president's son
is going to be charged
it was was charged and he pled guilty to
three charges one is a felony gun charge
from 2018 when Trump appointed a U.S
attorney in Delaware to investigate him
weaponizing government
it's always projection from these
[__] fascists always
get that clear
and this morning Adam Schiff boxes
Durham in a [__] little caged Corner
that that animal should be boxed in you
know uh there's another point in this uh
little back and forth with Durham
this morning where his reputation is
questioned and the reason why is because
he Associated himself with Donald Trump
and this motherfucker's like well it's
my mission from God it's not your
mission from God
these these [__] white Christian
nationalists I'm telling you what it's
deep-seated it's evil
and we need to get it the [__] out of
our government now right now I don't
give a [__] if they're prosecutors I
don't care if they're judges I don't
give a [__] if they're members of
Congress of the Senate they need to go
so now for this [__]
God God LED you to do this get the [__]
out of here God didn't lead you to do
nothing Donald Trump had an ax to grind
because he made promises to his [__]
toothless sheep
and the only way that he was going to
get re-elected he thought
was to prosecute his political opponent
Joe Biden and his former political
opponent Hillary Clinton by weaponizing
the [__] government
I just hope um there's a clip of Adam's
Schiff absolutely pissing on John
Durham's ashes after he burnt him to the
ground
someone someone sent me that clip I've
been pissing on his ashes please
hell
John Durham Donald Trump's Lackey Bill
Barr's Lackey
you know uh John Durham this is a direct
message to you I don't know if you've
noticed that your former boss Bill Barr
has turned on Trump because he's a he's
a [__] chucklehead
oh we're gonna watch clips of part two
of Grandpa felonies lunacy on fox news's
interview if you want to call it an
interview it's more like a confessional
with Brett Bear oh my God Jesus [__]
Christ this guy was bragging dude was
bragging on fraud social
that part run was a banger he's like
yeah man
[__] reviews are out and they're
great
I mean by great do you mean we were
saying keep going Grandpa keep going
don't hey here here's a bigger shovel
is that what you mean by the reviews are
great because I thought you did a
fantastic job confessing to Federal
felonies that you did a great job I mean
it was fantastic I mean if you're gonna
say look you need to go on cable TV and
you need to confess to all these
felonies that you're charged with you
did a fantastic job it was tremendous
fantastic the greatest interview of all
time admitting to the most felonies ever
what the [__] it was great great reviews
get the [__] out of here with that
nonsense
I mean I said it yesterday if the
interview doesn't bury him he he's gonna
stick around for decades like these
people are Gonna Worship worship him
even after he's [__] dead doubt me on
this they still they still think JFK Jr
is alive
okay
they think Michael Jackson is alive you
don't think they'll be like oh well
Trump didn't actually die
they're just saying that so you'll stop
supporting him
I doubt me there's gonna be a [__]
video that I'm gonna play on this show
that's gonna there's gonna be some
[__] dumb [__] that's got
Trump draped all over him and he's gonna
say into a microphone probably the good
liars more than likely it's probably
going to be the good liars I'm not gonna
lie
he's going to tell him into their
microphone yeah it's just all Bunchy
it's all hoax he's not really dead
he'll he he he rose from dead like Jesus
and he's not actually dead
he just he just he just waiting to make
his move to save us or some stupid [__]
who knows that could be like 15 20 years
from now folks
they'll still be selling Trump gear
after he's [__] dead
he's a cult leader
and is cult ain't gonna go anywhere
because they can't have an actual
Kool-Aid moment right like Jim Jones
killed all the people who believed the
delusion he killed them all he poisoned
him with the Kool-Aid that's where we
get the [__] phrase you're drinking
the Kool-Aid
it's where it comes from
him but he killed all those
[__] he killed well almost all
of them
including the children
Jim Jones did
Donald Trump I mean he's gonna do his
damnedest maybe to kill off all his
supporters but there's still gonna be
some delusional [__] running
around thinking he's still alive and
he's still controlling things it's the
military it's not actually president
Gavin Newsom
[__] like that I'm telling you
[__] you [__] you just did doubt me I
don't give a [__]
they'll be selling flags and shirts and
hats
they'll be running around yelling and
screaming make America great again while
they're giving the Nazi salute
I mean it's gonna be few and far between
you know
and they're gonna be the ones laughed
and mocked and we're gonna continue to
do that because it's so much fun
how [__] fun is it to mock these
people
they thought Durham listen these are the
same stupid [__] that thought Durham
was gonna slam dunk put Hillary in
prison for the rest of her life
and maybe Obama too because it was all I
[__] wiretap me blah blah blah well
we find out that I guess Donald Trump is
the one who wants to wiretap people the
people closest to him because he doesn't
trust anybody which he shouldn't
when you're criming as much as he does
you really shouldn't trust anyone around
you
hmm they're probably they're probably
gnarking on you
anyways these [__] Twitter blue check
Elon sent Trump sucking idiots out there
love John Durham and he was gonna save
him remember he was gonna prove that the
Russia thing was all a hoax that it was
all [__] it was all weaponization of
the government he was gonna lock up
Hillary Clinton and gitmo with Obama and
Biden and Hunter Biden I mean it was
going to be great
and it [__] the bed [__] the [__] bed
the only thing they got was a guilty
plea because the one guy got scared that
he might actually go to trial and get
convicted of a crime
so they got one guilty plea
that's it out of the whole [__] thing
they went to trial twice and lost
huge huge they lost
there's a
[__] dead fish at trial acquittal
full acquittal from a jury and John
Durham personally prosecuted the case
he was gonna be their hero and then
after the fact he releases a report in
this report oh my God it's supposed to
show you how how [__] awful the
weaponization of government actually is
it doesn't show you any of that the only
thing it does is copy
the inspector General's report that's it
it's just a copy they basically
photocopied it like Trump's been
photocopying top secret information
apparently allegedly I don't know to
sell it to Saudis for two billion
dollars for Jerry Kushner that's a
legend but I don't know you make your
[__] mind up do your own research
figure it out
but John Durham copies almost word for
word
the inspector General's report
and the Trump elects get excited the
mogla knights are [__] foaming at the
mouth
that all here's the Smoking Gun this
Smoking Gun has existed
you [__] idiots
foreign
he photocopied someone else's work he
worked for how many years how many
millions of dollars and he just made
photocopies that that couldn't have took
10 15 minutes
and the trials that he didn't were
absolute garbage they were [__] I can't
even believe they got a grand jury to
indict
I mean you're supposed to be able to
diet a ham sandwich right that's what
you're supposed to be able to do
and maybe that's true with these Durham
investigations maybe that's true
but it feels like to me that their hero
John Durham this morning not only [__]
the bed with his investigation because
the only crime that John Durham actually
found during his investigation was in
him and Bill Barr went over to [__]
Italy to find crime on Hillary and the
the Italians were like well there's not
really crime on Hillary but here's some
on Trump
and like whoa whoa whoa whoa we don't
want to see that hear no evil speak no
evil nope
we do not want to see that
because it would expose what they were
truly doing which Durham Barr and Trump
were truly weaponizing government for
Trump to win because he's a [__]
loser
and he can't win without cheating that's
why they say Democrats can't win without
cheating because they they can't it's
projection I don't know if you figured
that out yet that every [__] thing is
a convect confession and every [__]
statement is projection
it's incredible
absolutely [__] incredible speaking
of incredible have you been following
the RFK Junior campaign oh my God
Jesus [__] Christ they act like this guy
needs to debate Biden because he's he's
trending on Twitter you people are
[__] dumb
you are dumb as dog [__] the only reason
why RFK is trending on Twitter because
he's a stupid [__]
he he is uh listen
I want here's what I want I want
Marianne Williamson tyt's candidate
that's right I'm knocking on tyt again
for all yous out there
oh Tony's always knocking on the left
yeah I'm holding them accountable dummy
I want tyt's candidate Marianne
Williamson and I want I want Joe Rogan's
candidate and Steve bannon's candidate
Donald Trump's candidate in the
Democratic primary
I want them to debate to see which one
to see which one the ignorant left want
to support against Joe Biden that's what
I want to see
why not why won't they debate why won't
Marianne Williamson and RFK debate each
other why That's Mike why won't they
debate each other why can't we have this
debate
I'm calling on them to debate [__] I'll
put up money
I'll put up 10 pools money I bet Tim
Pooh would pay for that hey Tim Tim get
a hold of me man
maybe maybe we could do uh maybe we
could do a simulcast
Joe Rogan get a hold of me listen let's
make this happen let's get Marianne
Williamson and RFK Jr on the stage to
say a bunch of crazy [__] so it
turns on it Trends on Twitter let's do
that I mean they won't they won't get
any support they will actually gain
support I mean unless you do some stupid
[__] polls that are rigged right if
you rig up some polls to make it look
like they got some you know validity in
the primary
I mean the only poll that really matters
in the primary is the actual primary
itself you know
we'll see how that shakes out not I know
exactly how it's gonna shake out
I don't care if RFK debates anyone RFK
Jr or at Marianne Williams and debates
each other frankly they should just
fight it out amongst themselves
I'm going to show you a clip of Steve
Bannon talking about RFK JR this morning
and it gives away the entire game
it gives away the entire game and anyone
out there who isn't understanding what
is happening
with RFK Jr Marianne Winston Tim Scott
and some of these others Nikki Haley
if you're not aware Wahu Vivek is
and what is happening it's it's the
Trump campaign trying to slice up the
vote in the primary that's all it is
that's all it is
it's just the it's just Trump trying to
slice it up
and it looks like it looks like that RFK
is gonna switch parties that's what it
looks like to me
I'm dead serious
looks like they're gonna switch parties
vivek's gonna support Trump
he's going to bow out and support Trump
rfk's gonna switch parties he's gonna be
he's gonna damage DeSantis
in Christie and then he's gonna back
Trump he's gonna back out and back Trump
well you you think I'm crazy
I see it all clearly through this one
Steve Bannon clip Steve Bannon who is
one of rfk's Junior's biggest backer but
by the way there's a clip of Grandpa
poopy pants in this [__] uh uh uh
lunacy
lalapalooza you know what I mean lunacy
palooza what would we call it I don't
know over there on Fox news with Brett
Bear he calls RFK Jr JFK Jr
it's not too far off
but I bet that human owners had a Heyday
with that don't you think
wouldn't you think that Donald Trump Jr
sang out loud I mean excuse me see I'm
even getting [__] confused Donald
Trump sang out loud
that he knows JFK Jr he knows him really
well he's great candid and him really
well he's a personal friend man
like like JFK Jr still alive now he's
obviously confusing JFK Jr and RFK Jr
and Brett Bear tries to tries to [__]
to correct him
isn't it funny how RFK Jr Goes by RFK Jr
isn't that funny
oh I think it's weird
oh you think you just go by Bob right or
Robert
then he goes by rfkg hey you know you
gotta get the uh that Cadence JFK RFK
JFK Jr
I guess I don't know maybe it's good
branding [__] maybe I'm maybe I'm
completely off my rocker here
but this clip from Steve Bannon is
perfect
it's perfect
and really honestly I wish I could just
transcribe it and send it to a bunch of
[__] lefties like um people who
support Marianne Williamson the people
who say there should be primary debate
for an incumbent president that we
already voted overwhelming for to be the
Democratic nominee because presidents
only get two terms and that's it and
that's how it works in presidential
politics it's not like a senate or a
house or he's dummy
yeah you know I it's I it maybe it's
maybe it's uh um maybe I'm just being
too tough on political commentators in
this country and political pundits in
this country for them to know how our
politics and our system works boy it
would it would just it would just it
would just be too much of a heavy
[__] lift for these commentators and
pundits to know what the [__] they're
talking about
listen to me there has never been an
incumbent Republican or Democrat that's
had the debate and the reason why is
because presidents only get two terms
they only get two shots at it
we know that when we vote them in the
first term we know that us as a kind and
if you don't know that then then maybe
learn it
whoosh whoosh Marianne Williamson has a
perfect chance has all the shots she
want in the world so does RFK Jr in the
Democratic Primary in 2028. they got all
they can [__] find it out
as Gavin Newsom wins in 2028
yeah he can do that [__] them go ahead
whatever you want to do try to take it
to the floor of the Democratic National
Convention
in Atlanta I think the next one's going
to be Atlanta it's it was almost in
Atlanta this time but it went to Chicago
I think the next one's going to be
Atlanta but it's possible
it's possible so I'm calling on Marianne
Williamson and RFK Jr to debate each
other why not
and and [__] yeah I'll put up some money
I'll put up a couple dollars why not
and I'll put up 10 pools and Joe Rogan's
money and who how the other dumb
[__] that put up money for RFK
to debate a scientist
as if that's gonna do any good for
anyone
what is this debate me [__] anyways
have you ever tried to debate someone in
this day and age
you can't debate anyone in this day and
age and the reason why is because you
have to actually agree on a simple set
of facts to debate someone right like a
simple set of [__] facts
that you have different positions on you
can't even agree on simple facts [__]
out of here we're gonna debate each
other
what on the on the simple set of facts
we gotta debate each other that's the
debate we're gonna have it's not worth
it
it's not worth the oxygen or the air I
mean you know it's fun to joke about
it would be great to watch [__] crazy
ass Lune Marianne Williams and
and that [__] psychopath RFK Jr
debate each other [__] you could sell
tickets we could probably pay off part
of the national debt
that's how [__] that's how much of a
[__] clown show that would be
and that just proves to you or should
prove to you that these people who who
are supporting debate Joe Biden are
[__] Off Their Rockers
well Tony they should expect Joe Biden
to debate he did debate
I don't know if you [__] remember
this how many people were standing on
stage when Joe Biden was debating
he was debating some of the best
I I would imagine that the burning Bros
out there would agree with me that one
of the one of the most
the one of the best Debaters that that
was on that stage was Bernie Sanders
himself
he Buddha judge it's no slouch when it
comes to debating
Kamala Harris was standing on the stage
we had Elizabeth Warren up there
you don't remember this
you Yang gang [__] he was
standing up there debating him Joe Biden
did debate
he did debate
do you remember you voted for him
probably I mean most people did
so what are you standing around arguing
for about debating RFK Jr or Marianne
Williamson
[__] out of here there is no debate on
this he already did it we voted for him
he gets to run as the incumbent in his
second term
just like if Gavin Newsom debates 15
other people in 2028 he gets the
nomination he becomes the president he
won't debate
and for his second term he won't
or whoever wins
they won't debate because it's going to
be a Democrat right
right am I am I right am I right yeah I
think I'm right
oh oh I'm so excited to have you here on
this hump day Wednesday June 21st on the
Tony Michaels podcast
where truth isn't always isn't always
comfortable but I don't give a [__] if
the truth is comfortable or not we're
going to bring it to you we're going to
bring you the live facts real and raw
I'm going to show you clips of this
hearing of Durham of him getting [__]
smashed by facts and reality holy [__]
it's fantastic I'm also going to show
you that clip from Bannon I was talking
about this is important and and what
would we do if we didn't go through part
two of the the lunacy parade that
Grandpa poopy pants [__] all over Fox
News oh my God he he really he's a dumb
[__] man oh man I'll tell you
what if he if he doesn't lose any
support over this which it doesn't look
like he's really losing support folks if
he doesn't lose Support over this and
the Republican party is absolutely
[__] here I mean major [__] [__]
them yeah a lot of them step on rakes
let them eat rake speaking a lot go to
store that beat Tony michaels.com and
get your let them meet rakes merch today
you can also check out the pride package
over there
this was a suggestion by the chat Miss
loveseek
um suggested this in the chat in the
chat all agreed so Gabe Sanchez made the
great pride buckham logo here go to
store.netonymichaels.com and get you a
[__] sticker fanny pack a t-shirt a
tank top the tank tops are [__]
popular I think it's because it's
getting hot outside you guys have bought
a shitload of Pride tank tops God damn
send me your pictures on Twitter if you
want me to retweet it make it public if
you don't try to DM me you can DM me on
Twitter try Instagram that's not gonna
work very well or you can become a major
a member on patreon excuse me
just go to the tonymichaels.com click
the patreon link there it's Tony the
Tony michaels.com click the patreon link
there you can also find the merch store
links on there as well you can DM me if
you if you want it to be public just
post it on the Twitter and I'll retweet
it and picture of your tank top or your
fanny pack if you're getting ready for
summer and you're getting ready to to
really [__] [__] in these these
these homophobes cereal now wear your
pride gear on there and also do us a
huge favor subscribe to the Tony
Michaels podcast right now on YouTube
just click the Subscribe button below
also follow us on Twitter because
tomorrow we're going to vote on bone end
of the week at Tony Michaels pod you
vote on Twitter and YouTube Community
tab you can also watch this show on
Facebook every single weekday Monday
through Friday at the Tony Michaels
follow us on Facebook if you still have
an account we also broadcast on the up
wires Channel over on YouTube go to the
upwire.com you can follow the up bar or
you can just search the up wire in your
YouTube browser
are your YouTube search bar and you'll
find the up wire also I want to thank
everyone who is following us over on
Twitch we're growing growing growing
over on Twitch and I also want to thank
all the people who have linked their
Amazon Prime account to their Twitch
account and gave us their one free
subscription every single month you
gotta renew it every single month
and our numbers are down right now
because people have forgot to go
re-subscribe so don't forget to resub
every single month and let's see
um
hillbilly just resubscribed for the
fourth month in a row thank you very
much she says morning [__] em fam uh
Scooby-Doo one resubscribe for two
months in a row so don't forget don't
forget to go over there and re-subscribe
on Twitch with your Amazon Prime account
you can go to the Tony michaels.com you
can find the directions if you haven't
done it already to link your Prime
account to your Twitch account to give
us that one free subscription here's
what happens
here's the big secret if you got an
Amazon Prime account and you link the
two and you give us that one free Subs
because you can follow us for free it
didn't cost anything to follow us over
on Twitch but the Subscribe you gotta
have that Amazon Prime account and we
get two dollars well it's like two
dollars and seven cents something like
that out of five dollars it's kind of a
rip-off for that but hey it's free money
if you got a Prime account it doesn't
cost you anything to give us a couple
bucks a month so go right now and we
just had someone we just had someone sub
see look at that see
thank you very much for all the support
on Twitch and everywhere whether it be
YouTube Twitter you can also download
every single episode on Apple Spotify
and Google we appreciate all your
support here on the Tony Michaels
podcast
I got to show you these clips of this
durum
and testimony I told you um when they
released this report that Durham was
absolutely going to get wasted by
democrats in these committee hearings
when he was questioned I was not wrong
rarely am I ever so don't go anywhere
we're going to show you Clips to this
when we come right back right after this
break check it out
we'll be right back
Mark 60 seconds this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
[Music]
trying to remember all the things you
boycotted can really get you stressed
because there's no good way to keep them
from becoming a cluttered mess well now
there's boycott binder the ingenious
organizer that keeps track of everything
and everyone you've ever boycotted the
72 category filing system makes it easy
to organize boycotted people places and
things so you can find them with ease
the large centered area can even fit
your boycott sign but best of all when
you're done the boycott binder folds
right up so you can take it anywhere so
if you're tired of having a cluttered
mess call now and get the boycott binder
for just 29.99 plus you'll also receive
our next rep as a bonus just Loop it
around your neck to travel with ease but
call right now and we'll double the
offer that's two boycott binders and two
neck straps for just 29.99 boycott
binders brought to you by the same
makers of binders full of women
jumping back into it this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
foreign
[Music]
we get this [__] all over John Durham
you're excellent
and all over John Durham right here live
on the Tony Michaels podcast don't
forget to subscribe on YouTube you're
not going to want to miss a single
episode we air this show every single
every single weekday Monday through
Friday noon Eastern 11 Central 9 Pacific
for two full hours if you're a new
viewer get in the chat on YouTube or you
can go over to Twitch there's a lively
chat over there go to twitch.tv slash
the Tony Michaels also you can get in on
Facebook at the Tony Michaels you want
to chat over there I I can tell you you
can follow us on Twitter but I I
wouldn't chat live with the show over
there because I don't actually see it I
don't see the like the comments that you
post on the broadcast like during the
broadcast I don't see any of that
I have to actually go in and re-watch it
because
Periscope or what is left of periscope
that uses
um the platform Twitter to broadcast is
absolute [__] garbage and it's not
surprising
it is Elon and he hasn't fixed it yet
Periscope used to be a little better
like two years ago I think it was two or
three years ago two years it had to be
two years ago
um when Periscope was still the fully
functional tool until Twitter
um did something with this was pre-elon
I [__] it up they totally [__] up
periscope
but that's just the way it goes and it's
not gonna get fixed because it's Elon I
mean elon's is good at fixing Twitter as
uh Ocean Gate is is giving tours of the
Titanic did you hear that story
yesterday we went like 30 minutes long
yesterday to talk about this
this [__]
submersible it's not a submarine
whatever it's a [__] submarine it's a
goddamn it's a goddamn watercraft that
goes down underneath the water what what
else is a goddamn cell what doesn't have
seats in it oh okay well I'm sorry
and then I have seats in it gives a [__]
just because they were too cheap to put
seats in it I mean they only spent forty
dollars on the controller did you see
this they bought that controller from
Amazon it's 40 bucks they put some
bigger nipples on it I guess so they
could crash this thing easier I don't
know a lot of people are mad at me
yesterday for making fun of these people
but what else do you want me to do they
paid 250
000 to go get lost at the bottom of the
ocean
I mean you want you want me to have
sympathy for them the [__] out of here
sympathy okay
I mean there's [__] there's all kinds
of [__] that could be done with all the
money that was spent on this stupid
[__] thing now apparently
um authorities have heard knocking
some people uh it's just uh sonar is
picking up some sounds it could be this
this craft it couldn't be and they got
like 20 hours left
um of oxygen or some [__] that's the
estimate
I guess
but I mean the sound could be coming
from another ship somewhere where the
where the sounds moving through the
water because sound moves through water
like four times as far right
So like um a sound outside the water
will only travel let's say it travels
100 100 yards so inside the water it'll
travel 400 yards I didn't know that
they'll till this morning when I was
reading the report about this
about this this submarine
I don't know I don't know why I'm
supposed to feel sorry for these people
I mean I don't feel sorry for you if
Jeff Bezos got into his rocket and
launched it in the space with him in it
and it [__] incinerated in midair
and he's in it I I mean I wouldn't feel
sorry for him I'm sorry especially if he
didn't have any safety protocols and it
wasn't inspected by any safety agency
which it is on the rocket side but this
submersible this submarine
that you had to sign a waiver basically
says Ah you're gonna die probably more
than like maybe yeah you're gonna die
for sure and you can't sue us
okay
I'm gonna pay 250 000 to climb into my
own casket and have it sunk to the
bottom of the ocean near the Titanic
sounds like a hell of a bargain if you
want to know the honest truth
what do you want from me
I can't I can't have sympathy for these
billionaires and apparently there's a
one of the this one of these people in
this submarine one of the billionaires
in the submarine apparently
um his son is on social media our
stepson something like that I don't know
if this is a PornHub stepson type
situation or what I don't know have you
ever seen this yeah man you go to
Pornhub and that's all it is is stepson
stepdaughter [__] it's weird it's weird
stuff it makes it to where you can't
even go over there anymore to be quite
honest it's like a bunch of Republicans
making porn oh Jesus Christ
I'm just saying what do you want from me
what do you want from me we're zero days
talking about porn now I'm just trying
to get that that zero days in there
anyways so um the submersible may or may
not they still may or may not be alive
they're not really sure
apparently the uh the sound is coming
away from where the
where the Titanic or where they're
supposed to be is
so they're trying to debate do we search
where this sound is coming from or do we
continue to search
where we think they are
[__] matters you know what I hope
they find these people I really do don't
they find these people not not listen
not for the whole [__] the reason you
think oh Tony he's got a heart with for
these people no
I I just want to see the look on their
faces when they got like 10 minutes left
when they pull these dumb bastards out
of this [__] tin can that they sunk
to the bottom of the ocean so these
[__] Rich bastards could go get one
glance at the Titanic listen dude if you
want to see the Titanic if you want to
see it just rent the movie from the
1990s it's like 299 on Amazon you dumb
[__]
250 000 to look at it on a TV screen
go rent it for 2.99 James Cameron like
Texas Paul said yesterday James Cameron
spent gazillions of dollars
gazillions of dollars to get the best
[__] footage possible of this [__]
sunken ship
and you're gonna spend 250 Grand
to hop into an aluminum can
and have weights strapped around it to
sink you to the Bottom of the Sea when
alls you'd have to do is rent the
[__] movie Titanic for 2.99 on Amazon
Buck you could probably buy that stupid
[__] for 8.99 at this point
and you can fast forward you don't have
to watch the whole [__] movie if you
want to see the footage the real footage
of the Titanic that James Cameron spent
gazillions of dollars
the best footage that we've ever had
ever in the history of ever because
James Cameron is a is a dick head and he
accepts nothing but the best
just go rent the [__] Jesus Christ am I
off my rocker here Gabe Sanchez or what
totally Off Your Rocker always totally
Off Your Rocker uh no no no you're
you're you're not off I mean like the
idea that
it's it's like there's it's like a
combination of like uh
uh like hubris yeah and ignorance and
stupidity yeah
uh that somebody would do this right
again like you could you could do just
send me the DVD just send me the Disney
plus uh content that's there and I'll
watch it [__] it I'll go watch that
tonight do you know how much footage is
probably compiled somewhere on the
internet somewhere that you probably
wouldn't have to pay money to see the
Titanic like to see to see footage
because really honestly this this tin
can that they're in because it's pretty
much a 10 game there's like one [__]
window and and even in reports that this
window isn't even [__] rated to go as
far down as the Titanic is yeah and like
the the engineers that were the
engineers that were making this were
like whoa that that porthole is not
[__] that's not rated to go that far
down like hey don't worry we're using
we're using a [__] a wish.com uh Xbox
controller to run this thing no big deal
yeah no big deal well it's it's not only
that but it's also the reports that are
coming out of of how they're like hey so
it can only go to like a thousand feet
uh we're trying to do much more than
that
uh can can we do and then they're like
all right you gotta go you can't be here
anymore you you're gonna be fired
um but it's I mean I think last night
what I saw is like they were doing
um
they were doing aerial uh
they were doing Ariel
like scans of it and then they get her
like knocking yeah yeah but they're not
sure they're not sure if that because
it's not really knocking this morning
they're like ah it's not really knocking
it's just sound that we're we're hearing
and it could be a ship from God knows
where from far away it could be a
[__] dolphin [__] right it could
well it could be just pounding the [__]
out of it is that what you're saying I
mean is that out Dolphins [__] dude I
don't know if you know this but dolphins
they it's not just like oh hey I'm gonna
have like sex and rape other Dolphins
dude they [__] other things no [__] yeah
dude they're very aggressive in the
water no [__] yeah they like they like
dude they don't care man they don't care
what gender they don't care what species
they am they don't care about so
dolphins are Republican
no no they're the opposite no no no no
no no see I'm sure Dolphins would be
like in front of the camera they'd be
like oh we we we're really offended by
the word CIS and cisgender dolphin
um and and by the way we're transphobic
and homophobic
um that's what we are and then behind
behind the curtain under the sea I see
yeah yeah
am I gonna get knocked by uh Disney by
singing that song I don't know um I
don't think that you were like
people still climb Mount Everest yeah
that's dumb as dog [__] too however
climbing Mount Everest I think is a lot
safer
right why I mean because like you get
like gear and facts and [__] that you
need to know there are so many people
here here's the big difference
so many like climbing Mount Everest is
become more commonplace and accessible
over the over the you know the last 100
years or however you know people people
still die it's still dangerous however
the training and the tools and the
resources that you have way way better
chance of survival than going down into
a pressurized Tin Can at the deepest
part of the ocean to go see a a rotting
old ship that you could watch on Disney
and it's great footage that they have of
it from like 15 years ago that's better
footage than you'll ever get now because
of some [__] deteriorating right I
mean they've got they've got for anyone
in La they've got an interactive I don't
know if anyone's ever been to like the
interactive like Van Gogh experience
they have one for I got one in Branson
Missouri too I know what you're going to
talk about it's a Titanic yeah they got
interactive Titanic multiple of these
they're all around the country yeah and
it's like it really it's only it's only
probably what 25 bucks to get into that
[__] like that
where like Leo kisses you know [__]
Rose at the end after they die which is
I'm sure what the people I think they
have a replica one of the Rudders is a
replica yeah yeah they've got the thing
it looks like the Titanic is that what
it look because in Branson they built a
building to look like yeah so they have
a warehouse out here in L.A and they
built it inside so like you can walk
along at night right but on the outside
does it look like a Titanic no no on the
outside Branson and Branson Missouri
pull this up go to pull it see if we can
run it in Branson Missouri I'm sure you
not there is there is like the [__]
front the bow of the Titanic in Branson
just sitting out in the middle of the
[__] road wow they really went for it
yeah dude give me that link I'll show it
to everybody you do not have to go to
the Bottom of the Sea to see a good
rendition of the Titanic this is crazy
that you just don't okay scroll down I
mean you can show the photos but like so
what we have I I want to I want to be
clear here I'm not I'm not advocating
you go to Branson Missouri because it's
a [__] [__] but but um if you
really if you really if you want to
spend like 200 and some odd you know
what what is 250 000 is that what these
morons spent 250 000 yeah so here is
here's the this is the this is the
museum in Branson yeah that's what it
looks impressive that's what if you
don't have like in in L.A you don't even
have it in Los Angeles that's right you
have a we have a warehouse awesome
Hillbillies go inside us Hillbillies
when we do something we [__] do it
man yeah but how much of that have you
ever seen right well here's the thing
there used to be in in that in the town
I live in now there used to be a minivan
that was on top of like a uh uh like
like a like a Bigfoot chassis it had big
huge [__] tires and it was a minivan
what a nice minivan it had like a red
door and this door is green and this
Fender was blue it was like [__]
Frankenstein so when we do something
we're not like when we get an idea we're
not like oh yeah we go half-assed we
build the [__] Titanic and Branson
what is that is that just like a paper
mache Titanic outside [__] I you know I
I don't really know but I'm gonna assume
I mean there's obviously I don't keep
her machete you think yeah man how long
do you think paper mache would last out
in the open about as long as this tin
can would last at the bottom of the sea
no I I mean I think I it's probably [__]
I don't know what it is here here's
another here's another photo so that you
get perspective on it I mean it's pretty
impressive in terms of what they built
oh [__] yeah
my question is like how long is the
museum dude this Museum's been there for
probably 15 years maybe really yeah [__]
yeah oh they just brought this thing to
La I feel like in the last year look at
this so it's just awareness this is in
Branson Missouri there's a Titanic
sitting out in the middle of the open
well half of it and it's and it's a it's
a scaled down version right so this
isn't and it's even got the [__]
Iceberg look it's got the iceberg there
they even built the iceberg with it yeah
you walk in under where the hole was
there though that's what I wanted I know
I'm curious It's been there for like 15
years I I enjoy a self-guided tour
Titanic Museum Branson Missouri
featuring a fully recreated cabins
parlors in the Infamous 1 million dollar
grand staircase yeah so so they actually
had the staircase in there the other
thing they have in there this is [__]
nuts this is one of the best parts of
the whole thing there's like this um you
know you know what a bird bath is right
yeah yeah yeah okay so so it kind of
looks like a bird bath just a bigger one
and there's water in it and it's
constantly moving but it's the
temperature of the [__] water that
was in the sea when these people had to
jump off the boat oh my God you stick
your [__] hand in there you're like
Jesus [__] Christ so I mean that's one
of the best parts and then they have
they have a lot of um um it's a lot of
uh voiceovers so it's like Diaries
people who talked about it who wrote
about it afterwards and they you know
and they would they would voice this and
perform it and you you and you go
through and you can get a set of
headphones at least that's what it was
when I was uh yeah 15 years ago when I
was and it's been like 15 years because
my son was little when we went in this
thing it's been a long time but listen
I'm again I'm not advocating that you
vacation to Branson Missouri from the
Missouri Missouri's not a bad place
Branson this might be the best thing in
Branson there's a Ripley's Believe It or
Not museum which is pretty [__] cool
they also have that in La I'm pretty
sure does it look like the one in
Branson though see again I don't know
he's like Branson you have a lot of uh
square footage available to build things
like this again like I said in La all we
have is a warehouse right and on the
inside it's the experience and again
here in Missouri people are like wait
you just want to build a warehouse to
have a museum you know what we do we
should build it to look like the [__]
Titanic and people like how you do that
well uh get me uh give me a water hose
and uh funnel have you ever seen that
what the hell is that from uh where he's
making a bong he's the mechanic isn't
that uh what movie is that off of God
damn but that's that's literally
Missouri that's Missouri for you I'm
like no we'll make it look like the
Titanic don't worry don't worry we'll
make it look that's baked yeah I think
that is is it the mechanic making them a
diver smoker I think so yeah let's see
here's some more pictures there's the
there's one of the cabins they got a
replica of the cabin
um there's the grand staircase that you
can go visit we have we also have this
there's like Key Parts in La that they
have this is one of them you can walk
outside on the deck and experience the
night time with like a LED screen that
they've got going on is the water thing
there have you ever been there no I
haven't it's on my list I do really like
the Titanic I mean like I know what you
should do you should go do some videos
from there as if you're if as if you
died in in the submersible yeah and you
come back to life like they did in the
movie you know what I mean at the end of
the movie you know they all die and then
a Jack's Leonardo Champions character
standing at the top of the staircase and
then we make out and well yeah well I
mean Leonardo DiCaprio you might be able
to convince him to do that now that this
story's kind of just I'm just saying
like I feel like that would be the thing
like hey someone someone get Leo on the
phone for me thank you thank you thank
you thank you yeah get him uh no but I
do it's on my list because I've been
advertising the last year about this
Titanic Museum and I was like oh yeah I
really want to go check it out
um oh here here you go here's for all
the here's for all the uh the the white
Christian nationalism the only Bible
that was recovered is saved
wow is in the Branson Museum now where
are the goddamn drawings
huh oh you mean a rose yeah where are
the drawings dude I don't know man
I know that I told you that's my
favorite part of the movie
my favorite part but here it is here it
is again here's the uh the and I'm not
sure what the scale of it is like if
this is the actual scale I'm not really
this looks pretty pretty [__] close
pretty cheap yeah yeah I mean like again
and it looks big in the picture but when
you're driving down the [__] Street
yeah in Branson because it's right in an
intersection when you're driving down
yeah I mean damn they're pretty mad I
think this is built to scale at least
one a portion of it is right well it's
not the whole ship it's just like yeah
the front third or some [__] pretty wild
man pretty wild they built that thing
but also they these people that are in a
tin can I mean yesterday was
they've probably got uh 15 hours 14
hours of auction left because yesterday
well right now really yeah because
yesterday when we were on the show it
was 40 hours yeah right fast forward 24
we're left with about 15 hours or so um
you know give or take
um yeah Margaret on my Facebook says the
iceberg is hilarious it is pretty funny
they're like in case you all forgot what
happened uh we had that [__] real hard
the CEO of this uh Ocean Gate I guess he
called the [__] the submarine
Unsinkable yeah yeah he called it
unsingable but the other the other thing
that I find hilarious is that he called
it Titan which is so close in part of
Titanic that you're like it was bound to
fail oh why would you that's like
calling the Titanic too why would you do
that no [__]
Jesus Christ I just you know what and
and people get mad they were a little
mad yesterday the audience is a little
upset that we were making fun of this
what the [__] are you supposed to do
what am I supposed to look if these
people were coerced on this craft and
they didn't have to pay anything and
they're just testing this craft out on
any old Joe and they send them down to
the Box yeah I'd be like those
[__] yeah I'd be pissed off
these people paid 250 000 to get into
this but the way up GameCube the way
whatever it is not and not to you know
segue onto something else yeah but I
will and and people might be like why
are we you know why are we making fun or
why are we calling it out or why are we
on this topic the reason is because I
can call a direct a direct connection a
direct correlation between this way of
thinking of someone like I don't know
Elon Musk or Republicans and thinking
there doesn't need to be regulation
there doesn't need to be any sort of
safety protocols in place right because
we know for a fact there was no
regulation it wasn't it wasn't classed
in terms of safety they didn't follow
protocols because there were they were
none in place right even when it came to
the porthole when it came to
[Music]
um
you know the controls the way it was
built the way that it was just Jerry
rigged with Sharpie paintings and tape
you know in terms of where the rigs were
like these roller cost forty dollars on
Amazon and so you look at that and and
you you have to look at this whole thing
as there is a pattern at play you have
people who have a bunch of money right
who don't think that they're uh uh uh
how do I want to put this
have a bunch of money and they don't
think that they should have to follow
the rules that are in place they don't
think that they have to follow like if
you're gonna if you're gonna be the
thought leader you're gonna be the
person that's out there setting the
standard then you should be the one
that's making sure that it's safe right
not like ah well you know what you pay
me quarter Mill get on that [__]
instead you have something that's not
regulated not safety classed you have
the same thing that's happening when it
comes to Republicans and how they handle
everything else banking
the transportation of toxic chemicals
the way in which we we handle uh our
water supply right these are all things
and those are just a few examples of
policies that were or or or uh
things that we had regulated after an
event
that were fixed during the Obama
Administration and then were removed
during the Trump Administration and now
we're finding that we're getting the the
pendulum is swinging the opposite way
and we're getting [__] caught right
in its eye uh line of sight and this
this whole Tin Can pressurized uh
[__] hubris ignorant idiocracy
submarine that they went down in after
previous failures and and mishandlings
in in lack of safety protocols
I'm gonna call it out and Tony and I are
gonna make fun of it right because again
nobody forced them on this thing no they
paid a quarter million
they knew they read the contract that
said we are not responsible none of this
has been approved or regulated by a
federal agency
and you as a private citizen a consumer
are going to enter this thing knowing
full well that something bad could
happen
well you know here's here's what I'll
tell you too is that
of these people that are on this craft
right and they paid all this money to be
on this graph they probably have enough
money combined probably that wouldn't
hurt them to spend to actually build
and have someone who is a professional
at building these crafts to build a
craft that could make it down there that
is a specialized craft to go to the
Titanic alone but they're like no I
don't want to do that I'm too [__]
lazy right I'll just pay this bonehead
to [__] you know like you said Jerry
Jerry rig up some tin can that has a a
remote control a couple TV screens a
light from Camping World and uh we'll
we'll just throw some weights on there
some cinder blocks and sink it to the to
the bottom of the ocean near the Titanic
like that's literally what they did
instead of say I'll also say that you
know the fact that the owner the CEO of
Ocean Gate which again I mean the name
just was waiting for something to happen
ah perfect the fact that the CEO is is
in there right really gives a whole new
meaning to like the captain going down
with the ship right okay I'm just saying
well hey Elon I'm I'm I'm wondering why
you weren't on your last rocket uh test
you know this guy's willing to go down
to the bottom of the ocean for his for
his adventures and his hubris
as Gabe Sanchez as uh Leanne says stupid
is as stupid does
from the great the great movie it's just
and the last thing I'll say about it is
uh it's crazy because when we left the
call when we left the uh the previous
night so Monday Monday night it was like
oh move we're still trying to figure
this out right we're like uh not a lot
of expectations and then the morning
yesterday's show it was like oh there
were more details they were like leaking
this information be like oh this
happened
after the after we got off the show
yesterday it was like oh it turns out
that this person uh made made a like
alerted the CEO of these safety concerns
and then it also turns out that the CEO
it was involved in some fraud case in
Florida there's all these things that
are like now coming forward like oh man
a lot of red flags here a lot of a lot
of red flags that are getting into the
find out portion as people are saying
well you [__] around you find out and
and and there's a lot of [__] around
find out in the news today speaking of
sinking ships have you seen some of
these [__] man they are oh my God
beautiful beautiful and we've called it
dude oh my God as soon as this Durham
board dropped we're like yeah get him in
the committee Jim Jordan do that we're
gonna interview him and we're going to
expose how the weaponization of the
federal government was against Donald
Trump Okay police it's almost like it's
almost like we're gonna sink a
submersible at the bottom of the ocean
and get it stuck with a bunch of
billionaires on it it's gonna be awesome
speaking of billionaires did you hear
this news tube which one before we go to
this Durham clip
um judge Alito he's um Supreme Court
Justice did you know that he's a Supreme
Court Justice and he he took listen he
took fishing trips he didn't go to the
bottom of the ocean he just went to
Alaska and he took some fishing trips on
the ocean in Alaska apparently uh singer
is his name it's a billionaire in Alaska
uh maybe the only one I don't know
anyways paid like a hundred thousand
dollars to to to put Alito on a jet on a
private jet send him to Alaska it's like
a thousand dollars a day fishing trip
right pays a hundred thousand dollars
that's I bet it's close to how much a
ticket uh on the sinking ship cost
probably to get a Lido to go on a
fishing trip in Alaska yes get this Gabe
this is the best way I can investment in
the world I think Elon needs to do a few
of these to get himself back on track
for Twitter If he if Elon if you're
listening this is one of the best
investments I've ever heard of you pay
about 250 300 000 to buy yourself a
Supreme Court Justice Samuel Leto and
then and then you bring a case a court
case for your hedge fund to the Supreme
Court and they award you 2.4 billion
with a [__] B billion dollars that's
a hell of an investment Gates inches
it's a lot of money God damn it's really
really time to I I think Sam Alito is a
lot cheaper
um it seems than Clarence Thomas though
Well Clarence Thomas is one of a kind
well I guess so so he's more rare is
what you're saying so yeah I mean you
know I'm just saying like Roy Jr made a
joke during the White House
correspondent Center and he said
Clarence Thomas is an nft and there is
so much truth to that whole joke that he
and I don't have time to regurgitate it
or give it justice but if people want to
watch it just Google Roy Wood Jr yeah
Clarence Thomas White House
Correspondents Dinner joke and you'll
hear it and it's a beautiful setup and
he comes in around DeSantis and then he
comes right back and talks about how
Clarence Thomas is actually an nft
that's pretty good that's pretty good
but I I do have to say that that's a
damn good investment Elon should really
look into those Investments he should
just start are you sure that he hasn't
already it could be I don't know I mean
he really he's really got to get himself
out of his uh his debt hole with Twitter
um and try to become the richest man in
the world that might be a good way to
get there I'm just saying yeah and maybe
maybe you know what's crazy
and I think it was uh I think it was
Fred Wellman who we had on Monday
pointed this out on Twitter he's like um
it might been I don't remember I think
it was Fred though if you take if you
take the name Alito in this story and
you switch it with Sotomayor and you
switch the Billionaire's name singer
with Soros oh my God we need
investigations we need to send these
people a gitmo and hang them hang them
in the Public Square because Democrats
trying to destroy the world and all this
[__] that's what it would be I'm
serious no I I completely agree that's
exactly how it would sound if you
switched it out and you said this versus
that I guarantee people be [__]
blowing a gasket having an aneurysm
getting so [__] upset at the idea
that oh my God George Soros is the one
controlling and it's like
um I wonder if we're gonna okay all
right I guess we'll ignore all that
other stuff I wonder Jim Jordan is the
um chairman of the Judiciary Committee I
wonder how many hearings he's gonna have
on this on this great investment that uh
singer the billionaire yeah but how he
bought himself a Supreme Court Justice
for 250 300 Grand to make 2.4 billion I
wonder how many hearings he's going to
do on that
um what do you think I think he's gonna
do any hearings on that I think Jim
Jordan will say I'm sorry I gotta go for
a reason who what yeah I'm sorry can we
sorry I gotta go find a jacket because I
don't wear one
[__] idiot yeah Jim Jordan
um and speaking of Jim Jordan and
getting his ass handed to him this
morning in his committee uh where they
were like yeah let's bring in John
Durham this will be great this should be
great clips to spread around the
internet when Adam Schiff absolutely
hands John Durham his ass again this is
another moment where Republicans
overplayed the hand that they had they
showed the hand right we got the Durham
report people scan through it
Republicans are like oh my God this
proves Russia Russia Russia collusion
collusion collusion also this is a copy
of the of the the inspector General's
report it's existed forever and it's
also it's a it's an existing report but
also it's got things that are moved
around and rephrased it's the same way
that Comer's report about this um
uh we're gonna bust Joe Biden for these
illegal payments and this and that and
and the the weaponization of his
influence of his position
what we found is that when you look at
the reports they were just regurgitated
pieces of content that they pulled like
you were taking from someone else's
essay from a previous semester people do
this all the time like right right and
you're okay
right exactly but the only the only
reason that they did what they did in
Comer specifically is because Comer and
Jim Jordan they made a promise they made
a promise before they got into office
and before they took over the the house
that they were going to have you know
the chairman of the of the oversight
committee that they were going to
deliver
on a corrupt Biden and holding him
accountable okay and then since then
they have been unable they've been
unable to prove these things we've seen
in the last two weeks alone I wonder
what it is about it I know I know it's
crazy it's almost like they're project
games or something I don't know and so
what we found is that not only is there
no uh whistleblower there's no informant
they allegedly died so what about those
recordings where are they do they who
knows man they're they're with the
[__] chalice that you drink from from
Jesus when you're trying to get holy
great mountain of Youth yeah the Holy
Grail but it's one of those things where
where they've they've over they've over
promised right and they've under
delivered they said they were going to
do all these things and their whole
platform was we're going to get against
woke this and woke that and we're going
against Biden those your mother woke
away every step of the way that these
things have come out these reports these
uh new findings which are just
regurgitated previous reports
they're trying to Gaslight the American
people to believe that there's something
new out of something old and the old
stuff is pretty much a bag of [__] right
right and so now that's what they're
doing again is they they don't have much
to plan because the tapes never existed
and are now missing they know that no I
know but they can't they have to keep
pushing and extending because I've said
this before on the show is they've
overplayed what little hand they had and
it's way too early right we have until
next November right you have a year
we'll just play conservatively a year
conservatively to start putting this
[__] out there to influence people's
votes that's one reason why I was
excited about the charges against uh or
the plea deal against Senator Biden
yesterday yeah is because I was like oh
man this couldn't come at a better time
um like right now in June of 2023 yeah
when we're gearing up for the Republican
primary
um Dr Biden agrees to plea to three
charges one of them being a felony gun
charge yeah which there's a lot of
debate around and there should be a lot
of debate around that charge and the
reason why is is it shouldn't actually
be a charge because they use that
against uh people of color all the time
yep they use that and they put them in
[__] prison for decades over that
charge
decades folks I've seen it personally I
have seen it personally people of color
stuck in [__] federal prisons for
decades over that charge it's a [__]
charge it's [__] ridiculous I can't
even believe I I I'm actually really
surprised to be quiet honest with you
and I know it's their bias and their
[__] their their urge for for hunt
for Hunter Biden and Joe Biden to be the
thing that Donald Trump actually is
right it's their [__] urge for that
but I I am really surprised that gun the
gun lobby gun Advocates and all that out
there looking at this charge going whoa
what the [__] are you [__] me you mean
someone who's deemed an addict who has
had treatment and it has a firearm is a
felon is committing Federal felonies
when they possess a firearm which I
actually believe if you're going to
argue that the Second Amendment is
uninfringible then what the [__] is that
yeah you should be yelling and screaming
at the top of your lungs that it's
unfair for anyone including Hunter Biden
to have to not only be charged but to
plead guilty to that charge get the [__]
out of here with that nonsense now you
can make the argument for the taxes and
I actually think he's probably guilty of
that because Hunter Biden actually paid
back some of his uh which their
misdemeanor charges but he paid back so
that's why I think the [__] the
charges after I've kind of thought about
this the charges for the taxing is kind
of [__] if he paid them back in
their misdemeanor charges the [__] are
they doing wasting their time right
here's what they're doing wasting their
time if you want to know what it truly
is Donald Trump hired this United States
Attorney in the state of Delaware
appointed them in the state of Delaware
to go after Joe Biden and Hunter Biden
just like he was trying to get the
president of Ukraine the new president
of Ukraine at the time to investigate
Joe Biden Hunter Biden over in Ukraine
they were trying to get anyone and
everyone that they could to investigate
Hunter and Joe Biden to dig up dirt the
reason why Manga is so [__] pissed
off about this Hunter buying thing like
oh it's such sweetheart deal is because
it was the only deal to make for the
prosecutors right they found no other
[__] corruption they found no [__]
no Earth tapes and there's a million
dollars five million 10 mean 15 million
dollars listen there's none of that
exists or this [__] United States
Attorney doing this investigation from
2018 into Hunter Biden they'd have found
it they'd found it and made a [__]
prosecuted on it trust me it was a
political [__] weaponization of
government government by Bill Barr and
Donald Trump to use the U.S attorney's
Office in Delaware to go after Hunter
Biden thereby going after Joe Biden and
they couldn't find [__] the only thing
they found was he cheated on his taxes
and he he didn't pay him in time and
then he paid him and they're charging
with a misdemeanor and the guy's a
[__] drug addict and he has guns and
he admitted it not only in his [__]
book but probably to the prosecutors
when he was doing his profits right and
they and they said look we want you to
plead guilty to this felony because they
wanted a felony
that's what it is but the craziest part
craziest part about this whole narrative
this whole thing is this is all these
[__] focus on all of it every single
bit of and it's a nothing Burger yes
speaking of nothing Burgers holy [__]
the Durham report is a nothing Burger it
actually and Adam Schiff does such a
great job here of [__] just burning
down Durham I I want to see the footage
of of [__] pissing on his ashes there's
got to be out there somewhere on the
internet right oh yeah I don't know I'm
just saying but here it is this is
[__] incredible and then I'm going to
show you a a clip from Jerry Nadler
where John Durham himself admits that
he's a [__] loser but let's but let's
let's watch this here this exchange
between
um John Durham Trump's Lackey and Adam
Schiff the Don Jr was informed that a
Russian official was offering the Trump
campaign quote very high level
insensitive information unquote that
would be incriminating if Hillary
Clinton was part of quote Russia and its
government support of Mr Trump aware of
that sure people get phone calls all the
time from individuals who claim to have
information like that really this son
okay so so John Durham Trump's lack now
again there's one part of this this
hearing where John Durham's reputation
is questioned because he has been
associated with Donald Trump yeah and
he's like arm our reputation I was I was
given this Mission by God that's that's
one of the problems John Durham is that
your reputation is now tied to that
phrase that you're supposed to be a
special counsel and you're supposed to
follow the law yet you think God sent
you on this Mission you're stupid
[__] white Christian nationalist you
just tell us who you are but here's the
thing is that John Durham before this
he was actually he was actually someone
who was looked at as a really good
United States Attorney like they were
like well you know the same goes
everything Trump touches dies so well I
say everything Trump touches turns the
liquid [__] yeah that's how I say is it
good this is in this moment this is a
good example listen to him turn the
liquid [__] here the presidential
candidate gets calls all the time from
before in government offering dirt on
their important opponent is that what
you're saying I don't think this is
unique in your experience uh so you you
have other instances of the Russian
government offering dirt on a
presidential candidate to the
presidential candidate's son is that
what you're saying
would you repeat the question uh you
said that it's not uncommon to get
offers of help from a hosta foreign
government a presidential campaign
directed at the president's son you
really stand by that Mr Durham saying
that it that people can make phone calls
um making uh claims uh all the time that
you may have expected you're really
trying to diminish
the significance of what happened here
and the secret meeting that the
president said Sons set up in Trump
Tower to receive that incriminating
information trying to diminish the
significance of that Mr I'm not trying
to diminish it at all but I think the
more complete story is that they met and
it was a ruse and they didn't talk about
Mrs Clinton
uh and and you think it's insignificant
that he had a secret meeting with the
Russian delegation for the purpose
of getting dirt on Hillary Clinton
and the only disappointment to express
that meeting was that the dirt they got
wasn't better you don't think that's
significant I don't think that that was
a well-advised thing to do oh oh not not
well advised right well that's that's
the understatement of the year
so you think it's perfectly appropriate
or or maybe just ill-advised for a
presidential campaign to secretly meet
with a Russian delegation to get dirt on
their opponent you would merely say
that's inadvisable yeah if you're asking
me would I do it I hope I wouldn't do it
but it was not illegal Jesus Christ
foolish ill-advised well it is illegal
to conspire to get incriminating
opposition research from a hostile
government that is of financial value to
a campaign wouldn't that violate
campaign laws I don't know I don't know
all those facts to be true
what were you investigating then what
the [__] were you investigating the idea
he was like oh no that's there's nothing
there's nothing wrong with that like he
he it was all a ruse and it's like yeah
that's not the point the point is that
in an email communication which we've
seen now between Donald Trump and this
other person he said oh great you've got
[__] dirt oh let's [__] meet
it doesn't matter if they met and it was
a ruse or there wasn't any actual
information or dirt right it's the fact
in the intent that he met and said oh
yeah let's meet you got stuff on Hillary
Clinton [__] let's go right let's see
what matters and I I believe I believe I
believe the actual phrase from Donald
Trump Jr in a text message was
um what did he say that sounds great or
something like that what was the actual
what was the actual uh text message
because Donald Trump Jr dropped those
text messages on the internet when it
when it [__] when the story dropped
that they were colluding with Russians
and that's the other thing too is this
[__] thing where oh they weren't
actually colluding with Russians it was
Hillary like the Durham report produced
none of that the prosecutions produced
none of that it's absolutely [__]
the the actual steel dossier was paid
for by Republicans yeah as Republicans
um
opposition research on Donald Trump
during the Republican primary in 2016.
you [__] boneheads I'm trying to find
the tweets but I am fine
I'm
trying to find the text message but I'm
finding the tweets where in 2018 August
so almost a year ago or I mean three
five years ago yeah five years ago yeah
time
um Donald Trump said fake news reporting
thick thickness
complete fabrication that I am concerned
about the meeting my wonderful son
Donald I had in the Trump Tower is that
really what it is that's the that's
because this was a this was a meeting to
get information on an opponent totally
legal and done all the time in politics
meaning went nowhere I did not know
about it meaning meaning he did know
totally illegal and they are
disappointed that they didn't get the
information that they wanted right
that's what he said 17 in 2017 it said
most politicians would have gone to a
meeting like the one Don Jr attended in
order to get uh info on an opponent
that's politics
oh [__] no it's actually illegal because
it's a foreign government yeah you are
trying to collude with a foreign entity
which is which is helping a campaign
it's so much like these people don't
know how like what the law is wasn't
there a guy now I'm I'm thinking back
here in contemporary history wasn't
there a guy
and he's probably a Democrat for sure
that took foreign money and put it into
a democratic campaign and then that
person won as president I think it was
in 2016 that this happened do you
remember this they went to prison here
recently who was the who who were they
in support of and who won for that
foreign money being dumped into a
campaign who was that
it's almost like we could show that
um
foreign money was dumped into Donald
Trump's campaign by this political
operative
and he's he's going to prison for it you
[__] idiots any any help
from foreign powers is a result of a
election
um it's illegal based on Election laws
here is another little clip you sent
this one to me what's this one here this
one uh this one is just more back and
forth with Durham and uh Adam Schiff and
Adam Schiff yeah Okay let's listen yeah
I mean I think if you read what's in the
cable and what's in the report as to
what the diplomats uh reported was it
was a suggestion of a suggestion that
the Russians could help damaging
information as to Mrs Clinton
um am I releasing it anonymously right
and that's exactly what happened isn't
it
and I don't I don't you really don't
know
how the [__] doesn't he know this [__]
he knows it he would wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
he knows it then then he is committing
perjury here yeah of course if if he
knows
committed perjury well that is true if
he if he's if he's sitting here under
oath and he's saying that I don't know
what you're saying and he clearly knows
this stuff and he clears really know
this that that's that's uh he has broken
the oath he has taken yeah of course and
he's perjuring he does know he does know
these things uh people are saying that
the volume is a little too low yeah well
I'm trying to get it up here I'm not the
volume not the yeah yeah I'm trying to
let's see and let's see if this helps I
doubt it will because it's just going to
be loud in my ear when I always set this
thing
um but let's let's try it here and see
if it sells
sure exactly when you say exactly what
happened well the Russians released
stolen emails through cutouts did they
not
there were emails it's a very simple
question
stolen information through cutouts yes
or no I'm not sure that really don't
know the answer to that
the answer is yes they did DC leagues
yes well
Mama's answer was yes more important
than mine Mueller's answer was yes now
that information of course was helpful
to the Trump campaign wasn't it I don't
I don't think there's any question but
did the Russians intruded into
um I just want to get into the systems
they released the information and that
was helpful the Trump campaign right and
the conclusion in the ICA and in the
Mueller investigation was that the
Russians intended to assist answer my
question was Durham that was helpful the
Trump campaign right
that's and and Trump made use of that as
I said didn't he by touting those stolen
documents on the campaign Trail over a
hundred times
I I said I don't really read the
newspapers
you're totally oblivious to Donald
Trump's use of the stolen emails on the
campaign Trail more than a hundred times
and that'll Escape your attention
I am not aware of that I wasn't listen I
was hired by Donald Trump to weaponize
the government I was not hired by Donald
Trump uh to investigate him okay look we
found a lot of crime that the guy did
even in Italy but we laid that aside
okay I'm not supposed to look into the
guy who's paying me listen we're we're
talking about the weaponization of
government here and we were the
government that was weaponized against
[__] you can't really you can't
weaponize the government against the
government that's being weaponized to
come after the you know it's like
doesn't you can't that's you no you you
that's Durham right now is like oh well
I just I I don't recall I don't remember
I'm not aware right
um it's the old Marjorie Taylor green I
don't recall I mean it's a like I said
how many republican that hasn't
committed perjury in in a trial or in a
committed hearing where they answer they
have to answer these questions and some
of them they're like look there's no
other way I can spin this I have to
admit the truth and this clip that
you're about to show I think will will
show that exact same thing it's [__]
hilarious now if you don't know who
Jerry Nadler is Jerry Nadler is a
congressman from New York he's actually
the ranking member in this committee for
the Democrats and the reason why is
because Jerry Nadler has been a
congressman since like dirt was invented
okay he's been around for a long time
Jared Nadler is not good at this I'm
gonna tell you this right out he's not
good at this the only reason why he's a
ranking member is because again he's
been a congressman since dirt was
invented okay is that the same is that
the same dirt that that the Russians
offered just the same exact dirt all
right same exact dirt except that when
they offered it it was ancient uh false
dirt but it's same same dirt but but
they Nadler and does Grassley come from
the same dirt or he comes from pre-dirt
oh pre-dirt oh okay Grassley was
Grassley was around when they were
inventing dirt he was uh he's been
around for a long time yeah yeah he was
like you know we should do we should do
dirt yeah that's a good idea
corn in Iowa I bet you Grassley was like
the rocks and stones that they're like
hey right we can make dirt if we just
shave these things down right right if
we do that whole wind and water erosion
and then and then we have it hey don't
don't speak too quickly on the sign
stuff oh well you know yeah well that's
why with the facts with these people but
watch Jerry Nadler hand during the facts
it really it really he really shits the
bed pretty quick here and again Jerry
Nadler is not that good at this okay
he's just not and I'm just telling the
truth people might knock me for that oh
Jerry Natalie's great and blah blah blah
whatever he's [__] horrible at this
okay I don't know why the Democrats have
him as a ranking member I mean I know
why because the dirt thing but why he is
the one who is the ranking member makes
no sense he's not good at being a
ranking member nor a chairman he sucks
at it he's horrible at it but whatever
that's just how it works in the House of
Representatives when you know and
there's the power centrals but here he
is he's doing a wonderful job just
getting Durham to admit the [__]
facts about the investigation of the
investigators watch it's not correct no
I mean there were multiple parts of that
did it take four years to complete
correct okay and with all these
resources and all these people who you
were sent to help you investigate the
investigators you only filed three
criminal cases they only brought two
cases to trial correct correct and you
lost all the cases you brought the trial
correct correct in fact two juries
acquitted your defendants and all
charges and the one conviction that you
obtained the defendant pleaded guilty to
a single count that never went to trial
correct correct I will note that in that
case the primary investigative steps
were all completed by Inspector General
Horowitz perhaps you were better when it
came to your report for my reading your
report did not make any specific
concrete recommendations to improve doj
or FBI policies or procedures in fact
your report repeatedly references the
recommendations made by Inspector
General Horowitz almost all of which doj
and FBI have already implemented again
your investigation lasted four years
four years in Untold sums of money and
you still obtained only one conviction
you did produce a 300 page report though
and that's given my Republican count
departs plenty of material to spin
so he just gets him to admit that yeah
my investigation took that long it there
was no results other than one guilty
plea and I carbon copied and photocopied
the inspector General's report that's
like that's it that's all of it that's
the the gist of
of the entire Durham report now the
thing is is now it's an open uh
committee now they're not going to play
that
um other than live now it is on Fox News
I want to re-sho you this this was aired
on Fox News rumor has it yeah rumor has
it uh rumor has it that uh that they
played it on Fox News and then at a
certain point Fox News like oh [__] it
turn it off turn it off right well they
had to why wouldn't they yeah [__]
turn that [__] off right are you saying
it sounded it sounded like they were
like gotta cut it right now right well
why didn't they cut this then because
this is dumber than dog [__] oh my god
did you watch round two of Grandpa
felony I watched a little bit I haven't
watched it on but I watched a little bit
I mean the whole thing look like we said
yesterday this whole interview is going
to be put into evidence for Jack Smith's
investment oh and it's going to be used
on ads on in the general election ah
thank you Donald Trump
thank you for this now this clip here
he's talking speaking of Criminal
Justice speaking a Law and Order he's
talking about
he's talking about a pardon he gave to a
drug dealer right
now unbeknownst to him there's another
guy that's named Donald Trump that goes
to these rallies and he's like we're
gonna get the death penalty to all drug
dealers like he's unaware of this okay I
don't I don't know if there's two of
them or what and they don't communicate
I have no idea if there's one Donald
Trump that goes and does the rallies and
there's one that commits the crime I
have no idea maybe it's a q Anon
conspiracy theory that I haven't heard
of yet but it's possible because in this
clip you would think that there's two
[__] one that goes out at the
rallies and says drug dealers should
should hang in the Town Square death
penalty for all of them and then
um this little diddy here I'm not sure
let's listen I focused on non-violent
crime as an example
a woman who you know very well
was in jail she had 24 more years to
serve she served for 22 years she had
Thomas Johnson Alice she was in the
Super Bowl high quality yeah
I said how many is and she was on a
telephone call and they were involved in
selling marijuana mostly marijuana drug
dealer and she got like 50 years in jail
but she'd be killed under your plan
okay okay first of all first of all
Donald Trump does not remember this
person's name and the reason why I know
that is because she's like you know her
well please say her name because I don't
remember it right right that's why he's
he's saying that to Brett because he
wants Brett to say her name because he
[__] doesn't have a clue what her
name is he just remembers giving her a
pardon because he's like oh yeah we'll
give this black woman a pardon and we'll
make a big show of it and I I like I
like black blacks for Trump like that
that whole [__] stick yeah do you
like how I uh the other thing I want to
point out about just quick on that is
did you notice how during uh the the
most recent arraignment right number two
and also his uh his rally I think that
he had that day or that night right uh
people wearing white people were wearing
blacks for Trump didn't even update the
year it all said 2020. not even 2024.
listen with you we're not even like not
even just black black but you don't know
there's like no year right what you
don't know what you don't know is it was
Karen and Helen black
uh for Trump the blacks for Trump that's
what you don't know that's what you
don't know is that it's not blacks like
black folks it's Karen Black her name's
Karen Black and Helen black they're
sisters and they love Trump but they're
they're the blacks they're the blacks
oh my God okay listen to this this is
great let me back it up just a bit here
because I want I want you to watch his
[__] face this is great watch his
face when Brett Bear's like wait wait a
second watch this then selling marijuana
mostly marijuana
and she got like 50 years in jail but
she'd be killed under your plan
huh as a drug dealer no
no
now what Brett Bear is referring to here
is
Trump
knucklehead because there's got to be
another one that's what this is what is
making me spend this conspiracy theory
that the other one goes out on stage and
he talks about and his rallies at his
Nazi rallies how he wants to make sure
that in his new Administration any drug
dealer anywhere ever ever you deal One
Drug one dig One Drug other than to
Donald Trump Jr
we'll put you to death
but he forgot this Gabe Sanchez he
forgot you do you think that he forgot
or do you think he forgot or do you
think it's like a case of like Michael
Keaton in multiplicity and he's got
different versions different personality
which is like Law and Order Law and
Order right and the other one's like uh
I'll be a little bit more like
sympathetic relax for Trump I don't I
don't know I don't know listen my guess
is that he actually doesn't believe the
[__] he says oh boy ah there you go he
actually doesn't believe [__] he just
says [__] to get his the [__]
toothless idiots to [__] get all
right grease frame yeah that is he's
he's really confused like whoa well oh
watch it watch him here when he realizes
what Brett is talking about this is
hilarious because the line that he says
oh my God like dude you couldn't get
better TV than this this is great watch
this no no no under my oh under that uh
oh yeah it would depend on this event
you can't do it okay by the way if yeah
that was there she wouldn't be killed it
would start as of now so you wouldn't go
to the
oh my God you can't have it both ways
man you either kill them all or you
don't kill any Danny's like NADA
no no starting right starting right now
stay right now sickness okay smoke a
little doobie
okay doodle in the news maybe a little
Adderall line that's good but no look
look look nobody not no okay there's a
that's not how it works okay like maybe
like starting right now right can you
imagine can you imagine he becomes
president and he becomes president and
it's found out that Ronnie Jackson is a
goddamn drug dealer because he is
allegedly allegedly alleged I don't know
that for a fact I'm just saying Ronnie
Jackson is probably more than like many
people right many people are saying
Dr Ronnie Jackson great guy great guy uh
does a lot of Adderall my personal
doctor my personal supplier right he's
drug dealers for my son Dan Jr don't
tell anyone he's a drug dealer now
imagine imagine if he in this alternate
universe or Donald Trump becomes
president again and Ronnie Jackson gets
indicted on drug dealers he's like no no
no that policy starts right now right
now right now right now
I've got an orange belt in Cheeto chap
karate
kid
I think that's it
karate orange belt it's the bet it's
even better than black
I learned from a guy in Asia I love
Asians
Asians for Trump 2016.
there should be a [__] shirts
all right I just chopped you in half
with a Cheeto all the people are
laughing at home and listening and
people around you have no [__] clue
why you're laughing if they only [__]
knew if they wanted if you're listening
if you're listening to the podcast come
on over to the video and watch the
Cheeto chat
oh my God
oh
oh someone please don't cut the Cheeto
chop out of this show okay so so but
that's hilarious because he totally
would do that right like Ronnie Jackson
Breaking News Ronnie Jackson indicted on
drug dealing charges
cut to Donald Trump in his office behind
the tiny little [__] presidential
desk he's like look look the law that I
signed in law it starts right now so
Ronnie is okay he's okay he's okay
because that's what he would do it
starts right now right right now right
right right right now
under Joe Biden Joe Biden you can tell
you
that anyone could do drugs you know oh
my God such a [__] idiot how how the
[__] is that real how in the [__] did we
get in a place in our [__] timeline
that the dude that's the front runner
who is the former [__] president who
is pardoning drug dealers goes out on
stage like yeah we're gonna hang those
[__] every drug dealer gets the
Destin's and then he can't even remember
that he said that [__]
oh that thing because he did he goes
wait wait
as a drug dealer no no no under my oh
under that uh
under that
I mean
damn man he's like okay
yeah
oh okay maybe I did remember the the
viral video it's like one of the first
big viral videos uh Dennis goes to
dentist
and he's like is this real life is this
real life like that's how I feel when I
see this interview man I'm like what the
[__] and they're not gonna leave him
they're not peeling away everyone's like
oh there's a new poll out this morning
Trump's numbers are moving two percent
like you dumb [__] even if it's
real which the poll isn't real even if
it's real two three percent what are you
talking about this should tank him
[__] tank him and it's not it won't
he's gonna be their [__] nominee why
don't how can't you see this [__] yeah
Bill Barr is out begging people Paul
Ryan is begging people they're begging
them stop supporting him stop please
stop yeah but but on on the other side
of you know the coin there is they're
like please stop supporting him but if
he's the nominee right move over you for
him I guess
it's just I mean I just love this uh uh
and like you said it he goes uh I'm
gonna end up doing a what was that and
there's gonna be a [__] mashup clip
of
of Donald Trump doing that and then me
doing that and then him doing that I can
tell you right now there will be a what
was that and it's going to there will be
a moment in time for the people who are
watching and listening
you're getting the inside exclusive into
a bit I will do
uh and I will look for other if people
feel free to tag me on Twitter if you
have videos on YouTube that you can find
where someone is making a similar sound
to Donald Trump going
okay hit me up on Twitter so here's
another clip
now you thought the last one was stupid
okay like if you thought the last one is
stupid put on your [__] seat belt
because the logic here is astounding
astounding now I was in a space uh last
week Mario space yeah yeah and it was on
the Trump arraignment right yeah yep and
I was in there with a DC Drano Rogaine
you know who I'm talking about yeah yeah
yeah yeah okay so I'm in there with him
and I'm in there with uh Heather what
the [__] her name who the [__] is she
by the way she's some dumb [__]
ridiculous person blonde with a blue
yeah
oh yeah yeah
she's a trump lover for sure yeah and
there's someone else
um I can't remember who else is in there
but I was speaking to mainly DC Drano
because yeah he probably is the biggest
swamp Trump is the swamp dummy so I told
him and Heather and whoever else was in
there I forget who it was it may have
been Jim made him in Jim fart you know
that is he's Thomas Massey's Thomas
Massey's former Chief of Staff who a DC
drain on Thomas Massey man they got a
[__] Feud going on and I [__] love
it I'm [__] loving it but here's the
thing I told DC Drano Heather and
whoever the [__] else was simping for
Trump in the space I said look you dumb
[__] your delusion your
delusion you people perpetuating your
delusion is gonna be Donald Trump's
downfall and it proves it in that last
clip but this next one's even better
right and what I mean by that and he
didn't catch on because he's like oh
what do you know Tony what the [__] do
you know I'm like look I obviously know
a lot more than you dummy because you're
still simping for him and again you're
you're enabling him to say these things
that don't make any sense because when
he says them then you're like yeah what
he said like what what he said and
that's the truth Tom Fenton said it was
truth too like oh my God you people are
[__] just out to lunch
um Tom's sweaty boobs oh yeah I wear my
little shirt and sister shirt Fenton but
here I so I tweeted this at DC Drano
Rogaine right I tweeted at him I said
hey man remember last week when I told
you in Mario's face that you're a dumb
[__] and your stupid ass delusion is
gonna be the downfall of Donald Trump
here's a prime example so here's my
example to him about why Donald Trump
believing the [__] that you people say
is gonna destroy him it's gonna destroy
him stop lying to him about this stuff
stop repeating his lies it's gonna
destroy him I mean that's what I want so
keep going really honestly you want a
bigger shovel I'll give you a bigger
shovel here's a huge shovel yeah here it
is look if he needs me to I'll run to
Home Depot I'll run the lows like I'll
get I'll [__] buy the lot I'll be
[__] Harry Potter in this [__] and
say oh well boy the Lord do you do you
put a shovel that you buy from Home
Depot in a plastic bag like um Ben
Shapiro puts the lumber in uh that's the
only way you go I just want to make sure
period just want to make sure period
since we're going to pass out the show a
long stem a long arm on on a shovel and
you carry it by the base but from the
plastic bag and when it tears through
you you let the shovel drag because you
have to keep you have to be a man you
can't give in right and carry it in that
way you gotta you gotta own up well like
Liz says while you're at Home Depot Liz
on Facebook here's giving gave a
suggestion wire at Home Depot grab a
bigger rake too you might as well grab a
dozen yeah yeah yeah they're gonna need
them they're gonna need him watch this
[__] rake this is this is some wild
ass [__] meganomics here listen to
this Christie's like at one percent or
less many of them Nikki Haley's at two
percent she has encodone because
everyone knows she's you know highly
overrated you know I put Nikki there
because I like the governor the
lieutenant governor of South Carolina
and Henry McMaster has turned out to be
a great great Governor that's why you
put her in my position for the U.S okay
okay so wait just just it's hard to
follow stupid here it really is it's
hard to file stupid so earlier in the
interview Brett Bear questions Donald
Trump
um on putting Nikki Haley in the U.N
because he calls her [__] underrated
and she's stupid and she's a nobody and
blah blah blah so he's getting to this
part of the interview where he wants to
knock on Nikki Haley calling her under
underrated but he knows that Brett Bear
is going to throw it back at him in this
tennis match and say yeah but you put
her as the U.N Ambassador right so he's
got to preempt that with this stupid
[__] story that the reason why okay
here is Donald Trump's reason why holy
[__] that he made Nikki Haley the U.N
Ambassador at the time she was the
governor of South Carolina you follow me
are you on the truth train so far I'm
I'm I haven't lost uh I haven't derailed
yet
so Nikki Haley was the governor of South
Carolina
McMasters was the lieutenant governor
kind of like the vice president if you
will of South Carolina right so when
Nikki Haley took the job as the U.N
because Trump's playing 18 D chest right
yeah yeah yeah Keith Dimension chest
here chess he's going he he points yeah
it all set up even that's right in the
2016 election that's right that's right
so he appointed her
to be the U.N Ambassador okay which
makes McMasters now the governor and
McMaster was the greatest governor of
South Carolina history of all time thank
you Trump like that's literally his
logic here in charge in a
a a high ranking position very vital
role at the U.N so that he could get the
lieutenant governor in as the governor
correct
oh yeah this makes perfect sense oh yeah
now again DC drain on dude if you're
listening man this is what I'm talking
about when I'm telling you
that you're [__] delusion you're
you're enabling his delusions with your
delusion this is going to be his
ultimate demise
and this is a perfect example of Donald
Trump making up some [__] in real
time that you know isn't [__] true
it's not even close to reality
and you are going to repeat this [__] if
someone questions you because that's
what the Cheeto said we're gonna Cheeto
chop
Nikki Haley
cheetah chap
oh my God
okay let's keep going Brett Bear tries
to push back here
oh I was gonna put you up Tony
chap orange belt
God damn
Jesus [__] Christ okay let's watch
Brett Bear push back on this but he at
this point he's like okay I can't even
this is mind you this is part two of the
interview and right one of the interview
Donald Trump talked about or he was
questioned in in and challenged by by
bear about how Donald Trump said he only
hired the best people and he's only
working with the best he's making sure
the best and the best and the best right
and then he goes down the [__] list
it's like a truth pinball machine and
he's like a cheetah chopped him
oh my God man okay let's let's um
who let's listen to Brett Bear trying to
undo this [__] sandwich here give one I
put her over there but much more
important to me because Henry McMaster
was great always great and people love
him in South Carolina and I got him to
be governor of South Carolina that was a
very big thing to me and I put her in
that other position but look Nikki is
very low they're all very low so Christy
is like they're all they're all very
he goes they're all very loyal
she's so thicky
[Laughter]
what what was that what was that I don't
know what the [__] I'm sure he makes up
words too with Nikki Haley she's so
loyal and the idea that she's like she's
not even gonna get over two percent
[Music]
okay so you heard this whole debate me
thing right
debate me bro I'm gonna I'm gonna end
with this okay so in the in the first in
the first in the first 30 minutes in the
a block I proposed this is what we
should do okay since everyone wants RFK
Jr which there's a clip literally of
trump calling RFK Jr JFK Junior
Robert Robert
yeah a new Boost yeah
did you know Ted Cruz and his dad his
dad assassinated JFK
I wonder I wonder if Ted Cruz is as good
a friends with RFK slash JFK Jr As Trump
is Ted Cruz Ted Cruz is dead
assassinated JFK that was his uncle
anyways
uh so um speaking of RFK though Junior
that is
not JFK Jr that [__] is dead so
is RFK they're [__] dead dead dead
dead dead
like probably deader than the people at
the bottom of the sea near the Titanic
now
not the [__] on anyone's grave listen
Steve Bannon is obviously one of the big
backers of RFK and
um this whole Joe Rogan doctor uh hotels
is that the name Dr hote's debating is
[__] dumb as dog [__] and the reason
why it's dumb is dog [__] is because
when you actually go into debate an
actual debate you have a certain set of
facts that you agree on okay and then
you debate your position either for or
against what those facts are saying
right what your position is based on
this simple set of facts the problem is
is that the right doesn't have or didn't
get the memo I'm not sure if it's not on
their uncle's Facebook page they don't
have that simple set of facts right like
they don't have the simple set of facts
to debate or they're completely [__]
ignoring them probably the second but
here's the thing it's really stupid for
a presidential candidate to debate a
doctor it's really dumb if you're
talking about presidential politics
right it's really [__] stupid nor
would the doctor even want to
participate in this because RFK Jr is a
[__] chucklehead now
my my proposition is that Marianne
Williamson the tyt candidate since they
want her to debate someone should debate
RFK Jr like tomorrow let's do it yeah I
say Joe Rogan 10 pool Steve band whoever
wants to throw up money let's get them
to debate that would be quite the [__]
show you could probably sell tickets to
that [__] really you could but I
want to show you a clip now
for all those people out there who
[__] hate when I knock on tyt why
don't you just go get go get [__] or
you can stay and watch it be just be mad
at me I don't give a [__] because I'm
Gonna Knock on them now I want you to
listen to this Steve Bannon clip and I
want you to close your eyes and imagine
that it's a talking head on tyt saying
this [__] okay that's what I want you to
do and I want you to [__] find out
what the [__] I'm talking about when I
say that they're not good for democracy
and they're not in it for democracy
they're in it as a grift they want money
and they're getting your money when you
believe them and we're protect
perpetuate their [__] that's what
they're doing because listen to what
Steve Bannon says here about RFK Jr and
the debate that he wants him to have
um
let's get beneath the surface here this
is not about a spoiler candidate that
that's what they're trying to throw out
it's not about a spoiler candidate
he's running in the wrong primary
if you look at this new realignment and
remember this gets back to what hotels
doc what did Dr Hotes tweet out over the
weekend
he said there's a new semi-fascistic
movement going it's got Elon and and
Tucker and Joe Rogan and RFK and you
know he says the Biden campaign better
watch out and I hope somebody at the by
you know the officials are looking to
shut this down
of course what he means there is the
hotels that's his semi-fascistic is that
group
to him We're the fascists right I mean
he is smart enough to know what fascists
are and that you are fascists yes that
is true that is true Steve Bannon well
let's continue understand that
Robert F Kennedy Junior's campaign is
getting traction for one reason no it's
speaking truth to power no it's not he's
trending on Twitter because he's saying
really crazy ass [__] lies and
conspiracy theories that aren't anywhere
near the truth he's not getting traction
for his presidential campaign he's
getting traction because he's a [__]
nut job okay it's the same reason why
tyt keeps talking about Marianne
Williamson because she's a [__] whack
job and she's not a serious candidate so
they have to continue to talk about her
to get you to think that she's a serious
[__] to get her to trend on
their Network just like Steve band and
all these [__] talk about RFK
Jr as a serious [__] candidate but I
I will say I'm there are
a few moments as of late where I'm like
God damn it why am I agreeing with Steve
Bannon okay okay he attacks Margaret
Taylor green I was like God damn it oh
yeah totally go for it he calls Hakeem
Jeffries the man he calls Kevin McCarthy
a little [__] yeah you know what this
is yeah do you know what this is this is
a strategy this is a strategy by Steve
Banning he's deploying it on you the tyt
viewer that's what I'm telling you it's
what I've been telling you if you think
tyt especially their [__] Flagship
show is a good show
you are a target of Steve Bannon you
dumb son of a [__] and he's using his
media to pump out the messaging that
you're going to believe against
democracy is what he's doing he's
deploying this when he says his [__] and
you're like yeah I agree with that he
when we're agreeing with the truth he's
trying to attract you with crumbles
little crumbs to get you to go well yeah
[__] your Biden in [__] him because you
know tyt says it and Steve bench says it
so it must be true it must be because
he's he's subtracting you with these
little crumbles okay that's what he's
doing it's all a [__] Ploy by Steve
Bannon because listen to this listen to
the end of this
he is far from perfect he is far from
perfect as an individual
he's far from perfect I think or even
close to it about with the agreement on
President Trump on some fundamental uh
and very important
uh ideological
um
not planks but but segments vectors
lines of work let's say
but there is a definitely
anti-authoritarian anti-establishment in
the reason is quite simply The
Establishment in the institutions that
they now control have failed the
American people boom if you want a
[__] line from tyt that is a total
[__] lie there it is and Steve Bannon
is repeating it he's repeating it and
he's repeating it for you to hear it
people who listen to tyt and who believe
that garbage over there okay and I'm not
talking about every single tyt thing
because tomorrow we're gonna have on
major Ojeda and he does content for tyt
Rebel HQ but he doesn't say the [__]
that they say I'm not saying that every
single personality on tyt is [__] what
I'm saying is their networks Direction
and their Flagship show is definitely
the [__] poison the pool of democracy
that's what it's designed to do and
Steve Bannon is using their rhetoric on
right wing to [__] convince you that
there isn't a choice there is a choice
you got two choices Democrat Republican
Joe Biden did debate [__] he
debated he debated almost a dozen people
in the primary in 2020 and he debated
some very good adversaries Bernie
Sanders being one of them and Bernie
Sanders had a chance to win but he
didn't he did not because the people in
the Democratic primary chose Joe Biden
they chose him not Bernie and I'm I'll
admit right here that I'm not a fan of
Bernie Bros I'm a fan of Bernie Sanders
and what Bernie Sanders can do in the
Senate and and the the the actual job of
Senator Bernie Sanders and I said this
before that that the great part about
Bernie Sanders being the independent
Senator not the Democratic Center the
independent senator from Vermont who
caucuses with the Democrats is Bernie
Sanders get to say whatever the [__] he
wants to pull the ideological Spectrum
to the left in this country if you don't
understand that go look up the [__]
how it works now
the problem is is that Bernie Sanders
was never a Democrat he was never going
to win the primary he he wasn't he
wasn't but he was a damn good debater he
had Hillary Clinton on her heels he had
Joe Biden on his heels and to think to
think that Joe Biden isn't capable of
being president after debating Someone
Like Bernie Sanders and then being
president and accomplishing what he
accomplished as president and then that
same [__] who debated him on
stage who's a damn good debater Bernie
Sanders is damn good at this
now supports him a hundred [__]
percent if that's not enough then you
people nothing will be good enough for
you and what you should do is just flip
over to Trader TV news network not tyt
but Trader News Network and start
listening to Steve Bannon because he's
got a lot of [__] he wants you to hear
you got me you follow me that's why
that's why I speak out against them and
you're like oh Tony you're attacking the
left yeah I'm calling them out because
they're not doing the things to advance
democracy in this country they're doing
the thing to get their [__] grift on
sorry that's just the way it is that's
the way I feel and I'm not gonna [__]
[__] you and not tell you the way I
feel did I make that clear yet I think
so
Cheeto chip let's see I think I have
another clip that I want to show you
okay I definitely want to show that
because we got just a minute or two left
there's a clip out there if I can find
it quickly of um it's man it's uh it's
it's a great debate speaking of debates
it's two guys debating about an issue
here and it really feels like the guy in
the truck is a reasonable American who
just wants to go on about its way not
[__] have to listen to your Maga
[__] and then the guy outside is
yelling and screaming about all the Maga
stuff right like Hunter Biden and
bereavement Hillary Clinton all that
[__] right watch this is and this this
works
get in your car dude get in your car I'm
in my car
[Laughter]
I don't know but it's great it sounds
like I can just imagine somebody and
this is a It's gotta It's gotta be a
joke uh for anyone and if it hasn't been
done yet I'm gonna let someone else do
this
somebody underneath that audio track put
a [__] screamo like song was like
you know just like that that's right I
think if you add that it'll make it way
better that's awesome though he's like
get in your car he's like I am in my car
dude like that's America right now right
like when they're like no Hunter Biden
and Joe Biden took five million dollars
and there's audio tapes like no they
didn't there's no evidence of that
they're like uh yeah okay yeah I guess
that's a pretty good argument yeah
[Laughter]
somebody's real I forget who I forget
who made it but I saw a clip on uh on
Twitter that was like America right now
and they're like and it was the debates
between Harris and Pence and he was like
Donald Trump right Joe Biden Trump
Biden I think that was it was just T
brown what it might have been yeah yeah
it was them going back and forth of Jem
just saying the president's name I think
Justin at the time of their debate and
it was just funny to be like Joe Biden
Donald Trump trump Biden
I don't know I don't know if it was
actually Justin or Justin posted but I I
recall Justin personally I feel like the
the Tweet was so generic like it was
like America right now or something like
that so I don't know I mean you could
try and find it but
oh my God I want to find it I want to
show it now now I gotta I gotta show
that that clip where there's yelling and
he's like go get in your car man he's
like you get in your car you're getting
your car I I am in my car dude he's like
all right that's good that's good point
I guess you make you're making wild
point oh here it is here it is America
right now this is Justin t Brown here's
America oh there we go yeah here it is
Joe Biden
president Donald Trump Donald Trump and
president Trump Joe Biden on the one
hand on the other hand you have Donald
Trump on the one hand you have Joe Biden
now Joe Biden Donald Trump Joe Biden
Donald Trump Joe Biden said twice you
know what Donald Trump said vice
president let me give you a chance to
respond well thank you
um Joe Biden looked as a supporter in
the eye
and president Trump is not happy about
it Joe Biden would never do that thank
you Joe Biden but Joseph
I just need to respond very 15 seconds
thank you thank you
Joe Biden fortunately president Trump
Donald Trump doesn't understand
president Donald Trump Donald Trump
president and with what Donald Trump has
been doing Donald Trump Joe Biden
president Donald Trump Donald Trump and
Joe Biden
[Music]
to our friend
uh Justin t Brown there uh he's good
there's a there's a there's an exercise
that you do like if you're in acting
class or take improv or something or
you'll repeat the same word but you'll
give it well like I can be like
Coca-Cola and like like Coca-Cola right
and it's all about how like what the
subtext is and the inflection is that
you have and when I saw that video
that's I had immediate flashbacks to
class where it was like somebody not
saying anything but one word each and
then trying to communicate what they
were talking about right so do you have
you ever heard of Zig Ziglar Zig Ziglar
has a good has a good uh uh thing on the
bid on this uh he's he's a sales trainer
this is where Donald Trump probably
learned most his [__] is from Ziggler
but Zig Ziglar
um he he would say you know it depends
on how you say something and what words
you you know given collection
I I did not say he hit his wife
I did not say he hit his wife oh yeah I
did not say he hit his wife
you get that I did not say you hit his
wife right they all mean different
things but it's the same sentence right
wait is it Dirk giggler Zig Zig Zig
Ziggler okay okay okay yeah all right
Zig Ziggler go look it up go look it up
I just the the only reason I I well I I
had a buddy in college who would always
do that and I forget where I don't think
it was from that guy and I was trying to
remember if it was a it was a Seinfeld
bit where they're like
yeah like I said hello to her I said
hello to her right I said hello but the
thing is he would do his sense and he
would commit to the bit when we were out
and he would do the every single word
and we're like God damn it Bobby shut
the [__] up but it was always funny but
that's that's that's what it is the
inflection right I Justin does such a
good job at peeling out those little
things and making a conversation with
just the words Joe Biden and Donald
Trump so thanks Justin for that and
thank you audience for joining us today
don't forget to subscribe here at the
Tony Michaels podcast on YouTube We air
every single weekday if you're not aware
I'm sure you are but if you're not if
you're a new audience member every
single weekday Monday through Friday
noon Eastern 11 Central 9 Pacific for
two full hours uh sometimes a little
more than that and you can also watch us
on Facebook at the Tony Michaels if you
still have a Facebook account you can
see us on another YouTube channel the
upward go to the upwire.com or just
search the up wire on YouTube you'll
find the channel there go ahead and
subscribe there and thank you for all of
you who follow us for free on Twitch at
twitch.tv slash D Tony Michaels and I
want to give a special thank you to
people
who use their Amazon Prime account to
link it to their Twitch account and give
us that one freeze is Donald Trump in
your shirt uh subscription I wanna just
29 minutes ago secretly famous
subscribed to the Tony Michaels podcast
on Twitch with prime don't forget every
single month you have to renew your
subscription so go go do that as well if
you can thank you very much for all the
support on Twitch it gives us a little
bit of money and it doesn't cost you a
thing if you have a Prime account which
is kind of cool that's kind of [__]
cool I'm not gonna lie not gonna lie
follow us on Twitter at Tony Michaels
pod tomorrow is Thursday you'll be able
to vote for bonehead of the week on
Twitter and on YouTube on the community
Tab and you can download this show in
the audio form which you should even if
you watch it you should download it
every single day on all the directories
really it would help us out a lot uh if
you just go download it on Apple Spotify
Google it's free 99 over there you get a
five finger discount on the audio
version in the afternoon after I get
done cutting it up uploading it you can
download it every single weekday also
don't forget to visit Gabe's patreon
page you can go to what was that
show.com or you can go to patreon.com I
am Gabe Sanchez check out all the extra
content that he's doing for his show
what was that over there on patreon and
also why you're on patreon check out my
page the Tony Michaels and while you're
surfing around the internet trying to
give us support everyone's man everyone
loves the tank tops I don't know how
many of these tank tops these Pro
[__] Pride tank tops we sold but
that's probably the most popular item
and everyone loves the fanny packs too I
I think I might get a fanny pack to be
quiet yeah dude get a fanny pack you're
gonna raid over your shoulder I think
well no I think I'm gonna do the whole
that's what the cool kids are doing talk
to your son okay he'll tell you all
about it yeah all the cool kids are
wearing the fanny packs or the shows so
if you want a fanny pack to wear with
your pride tank top and get a sticker
that you can stick on your Maga
relative's car make sure you go to
store.dtonymichaels.com
store.thetonymichaels.com or you can
just go to the Tony michaels.com and
click the link there
to the to the merch store and get your
pride [__] merch today we still have
pride month and guess what if you use
the promo code Pride don't tell nobody
but if you use the promo code Pride you
get 15 off your entire purchase what
what a deal 15 off when you use the
promo code Pride at store.the dirty
michaels.com I can't believe today we we
invented the phrase the Cheeto chop that
is great that's great content
whatever you do don't cut that and post
it on Twitter there's no way I would
retweet it
I promise you I wouldn't do that I
promise you I wouldn't do that same time
same place tomorrow you know how it goes
Surf's Up [__] all the way to
the Bottom of the Sea of the Titanic see
you tomorrow and Surf Shop [__]
you've been listening to the Tony
Michaels podcast in your face commentary
of current events and political news no
rules No Boundaries I think we've made
that perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed
the show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow toning on social media
at the Tony Michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[__] em
[Music]
Murphy's mealborn headass Beacon